(rock music)
- I guess I haven't heard
really great things about it.
- I assume it's all going to be nasty.
- The other stuff I've
tried, I've kind of liked.
I like fish and chips.
- No one's like, "Oh, dude, we're getting
"British food this week, yeah, we just
"ordered some British food."
- Well, the plates that I saw pass by
looked good, so hopefully.
- I'm excited though.
I'm down for the challenge.
- Am I supposed to, like, dip it
in the sauce or something?
- [Man] The gravy, they
took a hard-boiled egg
and then just put meat around it.
- It's like Thanksgiving and
then just an egg in the middle.
- Here we go.
- I like that.
- I don't.
- You don't like it?
- I like how the spice is with the meat.
- I like the stuffing,
I don't like the egg.
- Honestly, it takes me back to
a food that my grandfather made.
- The meat reminds me of stuffing,
so it's way too soft for me.
- Britain has not really won me over yet.
(rock music).
- Welsh Rarebit, did I say it right?
- So much flavor in the cheese garnish.
- I like the salty with
the crunchy, delicious.
- I need to figure out where to get this.
- I would have it again.
It reminds me of an
up-scale grilled cheese.
UK is still not winning, but
it's getting a little better.
A lot better than the first one we had.
(rock music)
- Cornish Pasty, I thought
it looked like an empanada.
- It looks like a croissant
stuffed with beef and vegetables.
- It reminds me of a pot pie.
- I like this one, because it reminds me
of a Jamaican beef patty.
I could get down with this one.
Cornwall, I think I'll have Cornwall.
(rock music)
- We have a steak,
mushroom and Guinness pie.
- I love the chunks of meat
just swimming in gravy.
- It smells really good, though.
The meat's really good.
- It kind of reminds me of an oxtail
from the Caribbean, but
obviously less spice.
- I think it's pretty good.
I'm getting pretty sold on this.
- All of this is very filling.
- It may not look like
American proportions,
but I feel like the
food is just more dense.
(rock music)
- We've got the eccles cake
with currant and raisin.
- I never liked raisins.
- What about currants?
- I don't know what those are.
- You're not up on your "currant" affairs.
Look at that!
- I like this one.
- I like the big grain sugar on it.
I feel like it adds a good texture
on top of the gooey inside.
- The desserts are winning.
This is where England did good.
(rock music)
So, we have some British scones.
These ones are round shaped,
ours are usually triangular.
The jam smells so good.
The aroma (sniffs).
- Is it like in poor taste
to dip your scone in the tea?
- That's amazing.
- This clotted cream is interesting.
It's like butter, but more sour.
- British food is
definitely growing on me.
- In the beginning, I thought
it was going to be horrible,
awful, disgusting, but I will say
there are some things
that I've come to like.
- I came into this pretty
skeptical of British food.
I thought it might be gross.
- I wouldn't ever say
it's really that bad.
- I could definitely
see myself coming back
and knowing some specific
things to try now,
versus just having no idea.
(rock music)